oggi parliamo di cambiamento
cambiamento voluto desiderato e anche di
cambiamento subito
ma in tutto parleremo
qui scusate l'espressione inglese
20 elevato da mandare giù l'ascensore o
di come questa pressione questo un modo
di pensare cambiato la mia vita
mi chiamo anna lisa a 16 anni vivo a new
york per curiosità quanti di voi sono
state new york
quanti di voi non ci sono stati ma
vorrebbero a darci
primo
beh vedo con grande piacere
dell'interesse per la città di new york
è sempre molto molto grande e come dire
non potevo non parlare di cambiamento
includere new york perché per me
new york è la città il cambiamento per
eccellenza
dicevo adesso di accompagnarvi lungo un
percorso a tappe
ottobre del 1998
nella classe terza dell'istituto andrea
gritti di provincia di venezia entrano
due volontari di intercultura
in cultura un associazione che porta i
giovani studenti superiori che vogliono
vivere un'esperienza di studio
all'estero
ecco quell'esatto momento la pena penale
il penale volontaria utilizzato a
raccontare in questa opportunità in me
scattato qualcosa credo che quello sia
stato il vero primo cambiamento voluto
fortemente desiderato da
e in quel momento preciso deciso che io
sarei partita non importava come ma ci
sarei riuscita
sono quattro le istituzioni che da
subito mi interessavano
inghilterra stati uniti australia e il
cile
avevo da poco finito di leggere il libro
di isabel allende la casa degli spiriti
altri che ci leva avevo visto più di una
volta il film con il grande massimo
troisi postino
insomma mi ero innamorata del cielo
ancora prima di andarci che le mie
aspettative non sono tanti disattesa
sono tornata dopo sei mesi bionda
15 chili in più il parlando sulla mente
spagnolo
talmente era stata la mia esperienza
talmente mi ero ero avevo assimilato la
cultura cilena che avevo dimenticato la
mia lingua madre
beh del 2002
sono in macchina con mio padre
e domenica sera fuori piove caso c'è
diventa della nostra famiglia
solo che a casa io e mio padre non
arriveremo quella sera
perché rimaniamo vittima di un incidente
una macchina colpisce il lato passeggero
dove sono seduta io
mio padre ne esce
abbastanza velocemente ma molto mancato
io in quella tratta di questa sembra
lotto tutta la notte tra la vita e la
morte ma chiaramente solo qua quindi
positivo
mi risveglio nella sala di rianimazione
dell'ospedale di dolo sempre provincia
di venezia non ricordo nulla
ma da quel giorno che iniziano 12 mesi
tutti i 365 giorni molto molto complesse
dopo il coma indotto che da qualche
settimana o il fatto un bellissimo sito
oggetto ma qui fino a tutta la gamba
sinistra
poi da lì c'è stato il periodo della
federterra
girello poi le stampelle un po tutto il
percorso di riabilitazione
fino a che appunto nel giro di 12 mesi
sono tornata alla vita ogni tornata a
camminare alcol e di età
questa esperienza è stata un cambiamento
subito non chiaramente scelto da no no
la reazione è stata simile a quello del
cile cioè di grande vita e di scelta di
decisione da parte mia di voler fare
qualcosa per uscirne
15 novembre 2013
ho 30 anni e qualche ora la sera prima
infatti con mio marito marco il servizio
abbiamo festeggiato il trentesimo
compleanno
solo che l'arco non stava bene
da un anno e mezzo circa marco era
ammalato sacro
e il giorno dopo marco viene a mancare
sostanzialmente mi ritrovo da moglie a
vedova in meno di 24 ore
chiaramente nessuno di noi sa
come un qualcosa che non ci viene mai
segnato in casa con la nostra famiglia
sicuramente non affonda quindi quello
che succede o quantomeno quello che è
successo a me di cercare degli studenti
per andare avanti di nuovo prendere
delle decisioni tenermi impegnata nel
caso di marco in particolare i dodici
mesi complicati dell'incidente non sono
sembrati nulla rispetto agli analisti
vera sperti puntati buio
eppure dal buio è uscita volta leggiamo
su membri marco è una
associazione che permette agli studenti
all'anno di vibrano opportunità di stage
negli stati in
una delle aziende più rinomate del
settore vi lavora io e marco siamo
arrivati a new york io grazie a
un'opportunità simile quindi mi e senza
toccare la cosa giusta osservare la sua
memoria in modo positivo dando
un'opportunità alla terza opportunità
che abbiamo ricevuto noi a degli altri
d'attacco affinché anche loro possano
vivere il loro sogno americano
sono già quattro gli studenti che sono
arrivati negli stati uniti con questo
programma in tinta si chiama liz ed
università ca foscari arrivata a new
york due giorni fa e il 5 di luglio
inizierà la sua proprietà sua esperienza
di vintage
che ci vengo a parlarvi di tutto questo
corso è tutto dell'importanza di
rimettere il sistema le opportunità del
ri dare opportunità dalle persone perché
un concetto molto
americano molto anglosassone force e
appena ne hanno parlato sono due
trasmissioni che lo identificano subito
fatto mio quantomeno ci ho provato
saldi in viene vetro da mandare giù la
scissione proprio connesso con questa
idea di rimettere in circolo le
opportunità
funziona così se si è arrivati ad un
certo punto della propria carriera
sentina per decisionale si è raggiunto
un obiettivo perché non può andare giù
l'ascensore e far salire qualcun altro
visite volee che lamenta
ecco questo sistema virtuoso qualcosa
che ho sempre amato negli stati uniti e
quindi ho cercato di trasportarlo anche
nella nostra italia vedo che ha successo
e spero nel futuro di poter espandere
questa iniziativa
ecco quindi cambiamento cambiamento
positivo negativo cambiamento desiderato
il cambiamento
imposto subito oppure la formula la
risposta sembra stessa cioè dobbiamo noi
con il nostro coraggio con le nostre
decisioni
rendere il video giusto magari
prendevano sbagliato e tornare in pro
ecco avere un'evoluzione della nostra
vita non
ricopre
chi si ferma
si beh chi si ferma si impegna
prendo che l'unico modo per continuare a
rimanere attivi e continuare le
motivazioni della mia vita si sa
usare quella fiamma che ognuno abbiamo
gli imprenditori che arte per motivi
veramente diversi di voi in questa
stanza per me ma per il mio lavoro mi
occupo di comunicazione e branding
sicuramente hard e per me per il parco
poi c'è un terzo un terzo l'evento per
il quale art punto che è la scrittura
lancio un asset nel mio secondo libro
l'ultimo capitolo è intitolato
talvolta
la protagonista anna venier e atene
francisco e racconta la sua storia un po
come sto facendo io oggi
come se questa storia che raccontato e
scritto ormai un paio d'anni fa si fosse
materializzato quindi per me è un grande
piacere
qui
le